Salut. En fait, c'est "Salut" en caractère Bauer Bodoni
pour les maniaques de la typographie parmi nous.
Un des sujets qui semble ressortir
clairement ces deux derniers jours
est ce besoin de concilier les aspirations des "grands" -
les "Grands" étant les entreprises, les systèmes, les pays-
et ce que veulent les "Petits" - les individus, les personnes.
Et comment réunir ces deux extrêmes ?
J'ai trouvé que Charlie Ledbetter a parlé, hier, de façon très claire
du besoin de pousser les consommateurs, les individus
à s'impliquer dans les processus de création
Et c'est ce dont je souhaite parler aujourd'hui.
Donc, faire contribuer le "Petit" à la création du "Grand",
je pense que c'est quelque chose en quoi nous croyons - quelque chose en quoi je crois,
et une chose à laquelle nous donnons vie en quelque sorte
à travers ce que nous faisons à Ideo.
J'ai intitulé ce premier chapitre - pour les anglais dans la salle -
La vision éblouissante de l'évidence même.
Souvent, les bonnes idées sont juste sous notre nez,
du coup, on passe à côté en fait. Et je pense que, souvent,
ne ne faisons en fait que tenir le miroir devant nos clients en disant :
"C'est pas vrai ! vous savez, voilà ce qui se passe vraiment".
Et plutôt que d'en parler en théorie,
je pense que je vais juste vous montrer un exemple.
Les responsables d'un groupement hospitalier important situé dans le Minnesota nous ont demandé
de leur décrire l'expérience vécue par leurs patients.
Et je pense qu'ils s'attendaient -
ayant beaucoup travaillé avec des consultants par le passé -
je pense qu'ils s'attendaient à voir une sorte d'affreux organigramme
avec des centaines de bulles schématisant ceci, cela...
et toutes sortes de tracés.
Ou même pire, une horrible présentation sur Powerpoint
avec des graphiques et toutes sortes de, vous savez, Dieu sait quoi, enfin bref.
La première chose que nous ayons véritablement partagée avec eux était ceci.
Je vais le laisser sur lecture jusqu'à ce que vos globes oculaires se dissolvent complètement.
Le film a commencé depuis 59 secondes.
Ca fait une minute 59.
Trois minutes 19.
Je pense qu'il se passe quelque chose. Je pense qu'une tête devrait apparaître dans une seconde.
Cinq minutes dix.
Cinq minutes 58.
Six minutes 20.
Nous leur avons montré toute la bande,
et ils se demandaient tous, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Et le fait est que quand vous êtes allongé dans un lit d'hôpital toute la journée,
tout ce que vous faites, c'est regarder le plafond, et c'est vraiment une expérience merdique.
Et simplement en vous mettant dans la position du patient.
Voici Christian, qui travaille avec nous à Ideo.
Il est juste resté allongé sur le lit d'hôpital,
et a fixé les dalles en polystyrène du plafond
pendant un très long moment.
Voilà à quoi ressemble le quotidien d'un patient à l'hôpital.
Et ils étaient, comment dire, surpris d'être passé à côté d'une telle évidence.
Oh, mon Dieu. Alors, voir la situation
du point de vue de la personne extérieure -
par opposition à la position habituelle de l'entreprise en interne -
c'était pour ces gens, une telle révélation.
Ce qui constitua une compréhension vraiment catalytique pour eux.
Ils sont rapidement passé à l'action.
Ils se sont dit, bon, il ne s'agit pas de changer notre système
il ne s'agit pas de faire de grands changements énormes et ridicules.
Il s'agit de toutes petites choses qui peuvent faire une grand différence.
Alors, nous avons commencé avec eux en faisant des prototypes de petits changements
qui pouvaient avoir un impact important.
La première chose que nous ayons faite a été de prendre un petit rétroviseur de vélo
que nous avons accroché avec un adhésif ici, sur un brancard, un lit d'hôpital,
de telle sorte que lorsqu' une infirmière ou un médecin vous pousse d'un endroit à l'autre,
vous pouvez en fait leur parler.
Vous pouvez les voir dans votre rétroviseur,
cela créait donc un petit échange humain.
Un petit exemple de quelque chose qu'ils pouvaient faire.
Il est intéressant de noter que les infirmières se sont prises au jeu -
elles ont dit, d'accord, on a compris l'idée. Que pouvons-nous faire ?
La première chose qu'elles entreprirent fut de décorer le plafond.
Ce qui je pense était vraiment - J'ai montré ceci à ma mère récemment.
A mon avis, ma mère doit penser maintenant que je suis une sorte de décorateur d'intérieur.
C'est ce que je fais pour gagner ma vie - une sorte de Laurence Llewelyn-Bowen.
Ce n'est pas particulièrement la meilleure solution du monde en matière de design
pour ceux d'entre nous qui sont vraiment des designers purs et durs.
Mais cela reste néanmoins une merveille d'empathie pour l'autre.
Des choses qu'elles ont commencé à faire d'elles-mêmes -
comme changer le revêtement du sol à l'entrée de la chambre du patient
ce qui voulait dire, "C'est ma chambre. C'est mon espace personnel," -
était vraiment une idée intéressante du point de vue du design.
Vous passiez donc de l'espace public à l'espace privé.
une autre idée, encore, qu'une des infirmières a eu - que j'adore -
était qu'elles ont utilisé de simple tableaux blancs de réunion,
et les ont installés sur un mur de la chambre du patient,
et puis ont mis cet autocollant dessus.
De cette façon, ce que vous pouviez faire en fait, c'était entrer dans la chambre
et écrire des messages au malade de cette chambre,
ce qui était adorable.
De toutes petites idées ont donc un impact important.
J'ai pensé que c'était un très, très bel exemple.
Bon, ce n'est pas particulièrement une nouvelle idée,
chercher des opportunité dans votre environnement immédiat
et les transformer en solution.
Les inventions ont une histoire.
Je vais lire ce qui suit pour bien prononcer les noms.
Joan Ganz Cooney a vu sa fille - descendue un samedi matin,
Elle a vu sa fille regardant le signal test de la télévision,
un matin, en attendant que les programmes commencent
et de là est né "1 rue Sésame".
Malcolm McLean devait déménager dans un autre pays
et se demandait pourquoi ces gars mettaient du temps
à charger les caisses à bord du bateau.
Et il inventa le container de transport
Georges de Mestral - Ce ne sont pas des punaises sur une Birkenstock -
promenait son chien dans un pré et a été recouvert de fruits de bardane,
une sorte de graine recouverte de crochets, et de là est né le Velcro.
Enfin, pour les Anglais, Percy Shaw - c'est une grande invention anglaise -
a vu les yeux d'un chat sur le côté de la route,
alors qu'il rentrait chez lui en voiture une nuit, et de là est né le dispositif rétro-réfléchissant.
Il s'agit donc simplement d'utiliser ses yeux dans la plupart des cas,
en voyant les choses pour la première fois, en les voyant d'un oeil nouveau
et en les utilisant comme une occasion de créer de nouvelles choses.
La deuxième chose, sans paraître excessivement Zen,
et c'est une citation de Buddha :
"Se mettre en retrait, regarder la surface des choses
est souvent une façon vraiment intéressante de commencer".
Une vision limitée tend à apporter, je pense, des idées limitées.
Alors, voir large, en utilisant sa vision périphérique,
est une position vraiment intéressante pour chercher des possibilités.
Encore un autre exemple médical ici.
Un fabricant d'appareils nous a demandé -
Nous avons conçu le PDA et le Treo.
Nous avons conçu de nombreux appareils chics à Ideo -
Ils ont vu cela et ont voulu un peu d'esthétique dans leur technologie
pour les diagnostics médicaux.
Ceci était un appareil qu'une infirmière utilisait
pour la ponction lombaire à l'hôpital.
Il était demandé aux infirmières de saisir les données.
Et ils ont eu cette vision de l'infirmière, appuyant de partout
sur cet appareil en aluminium
comme sur une sorte de gadget incroyable.
Lorsque nous y sommes réellement allés et avons vu réaliser cet acte -
et j'expliquerai cela dans une seconde -
il était devenu évident qu'il avait une dimension humaine à cela
dont ils ne se rendaient pas vraiment compte.
Quand vous avez une aiguille de dix centimètres dans votre colonne vertébrale -
ce qui était l'acte correspondant à ce dispositif de données -
c'était pour soulager la douleur. Vous avez la trouille - vous flippez.
Et alors, la première chose que pratiquement chaque infirmière faisait,
était de tenir la main des patients pour les rassurer. un geste humain -
qui rendait la fameuse saisie à deux mains complètement impossible.
Alors, ce que nous avons dessiné, beaucoup moins chic
mais beaucoup plus humain et pratique, était ceci.
Voilà, ce n'est pas un ordinateur de poche comme on pourrait l'imaginer,
mais il a un dérouleur vous permettant de tout faire avec une main.
Alors, encore, pour en revenir à cela - l'idée qu'un tout petit geste humain
a dicté le dessein de ce produit.
Et je pense que cela est vraiment, vraiment important.
Voilà, encore, cette idée de "détourner les choses".
Nous utilisons beaucoup cette expression "détourner les choses",
c'est en quelque sorte observer les choses autour de nous. En fait, j'observais ce qui ce passait à TED
et je regarde juste ce qui se passe
depuis que je suis ici.
Cette idée de la manière dont les gens bricolent des solutions dans nos vies -
et les choses que l'on fait dans notre environnement
quelque peu inconsciemment, mais qui ont un énorme potentiel -
est quelque chose que nous observons beaucoup.
Nous avons écrit un livre récemment, je pense que vous avez dû le recevoir,
intitulé "Les actes irréfléchis ?"
Il traite surtout de ce genre de choses que les gens font sans réfléchir,
qui présentent un immense dessein et une grande occasion.
Pourquoi suivons-nous spontanément une ligne dans la rue ?
C'est une photo d'un métro japonnais.
Les gens suivent consciemment les lignes, pourquoi? Mystère.
Pourquoi aligne-t-on la brique de lait carrée sur la barrière carrée ?
parce que nous devons le faire en quelque sorte - c'est plus fort que nous.
Nous ne savons pas pourquoi, mais nous le faisons.
Pourquoi accroche-t-on le fil du sachet de thé à la poignée de la tasse ?
Encore une fois, c'est comme si nous utilisions le monde autour de nous
pour créer nos propres solutions en matière de design.
Et on dit toujours à nos clients "Vous devriez examiner ce genre de chose.
C'est vraiment important. C'est vraiment vital".
Voilà des gens concevant leurs propres expériences.
On peut en retirer quelque chose.
Nous supposons en quelque sorte, que parce qu'il y a un poteau dans la rue,
il est normal de l'utiliser, alors nous laissons notre chariot de course la-bàs.
Il est là pour qu'on l'utilise, à un certain point.
Alors, encore, nous sollicitons en quelque sorte notre environnement
pour faire toutes ces différentes choses.
Nous sollicitons d'autres expériences -
nous prenons un objet pour le transférer à quelque chose d'autre.
Et celle-ci est ma préférée. Ma mère avait l'habitude de me dire,
"Ce n'est pas parce que ta soeur saute dans le lac, que tu dois la suivre".
Mais, bien sûr, on le fait tous. On se suit les uns les autres tous les jours.
Alors on suppose
que parce que quelqu'un a fait quelque chose,
cela nous autorise à faire la même chose.
Et il y a une sorte de sémaphore en permanence autour de nous.
Par exemple, un sac en plastic veut dire "parc-mètre hors service".
Et on sait comment lire ces signaux aujourd'hui.
Nous nous parlons tous dans ce langage fortement visuel
sans réaliser ce que nous faisons.
La troisième partie correspond à cette idée de ne pas savoir,
de se mettre consciemment en retrait.
Je parle de situations où on ne réfléchit pas tout le temps.
Comme si on avait un cerveau tout neuf, après avoir subit un lavage de cerveau
pour voir les choses d'un oeil nouveau.
Un de mes amis était designer à IKEA,
et son patron lui demanda
d'aider à concevoir un meuble de rangement pour enfants.
C'est la bibliothèque "Billy" - c'est le produit le plus vendu à IKEA.
Ces pièces s'emboîtent. On pourrait les assembler avec une chaussure,
car elles sont impossibles à assembler.
Mais la bibliothèque s'est bien vendue. Comment adapter cela pour les enfants ?
En réalité, lorsque vous regardez des enfants,
les enfants ne pensent pas aux choses comme le rangement en termes linéaires.
Les enfants voient ce qui est permis d'une manière très différente.
Les enfants vivent sur les choses. Ils vivent en-dessous des choses.
Ils vivent autour des choses,
tout comme leur relation avec l'environnement,
et leur idée du rangement est complètement différente.
Alors la première chose à faire - voici Graham, le designer -¾
est en quelque sorte, de vous mettre à leur place. Et donc, le voilà
assis sous la table.
Alors, qu'en est-il ressorti ?
Voici le système de rangement qu'il a conçu.
Je vous entends tous demander, mais qu'est ce que c'est ? Non, je n'ai rien entendu.
(Rires.)
C'est ceci, et je pense que c'est une idée vraiment mignonne.
c'est une façon complètement différente de voir la situation.
C'est une solution vraiment empathique -
mis à part le fait que la peluche ne l'apprécie probablement pas.
(Rires)
Mais c'est vraiment une belle façon de réinventer l'ordinaire,
et je pense que c'est quelque chose.
Et le fait de se mettre à la place de la personne,
et je pense que c'est l'un des sujets que j'ai encore entendu
à cette conférence c'est comment se mettre à la place
d'autres individus et vraiment ressentir ce qu'ils ressentent ?
Et puis utiliser cette information pour trouver des idées ?
Et je pense que c'est ce dont il est vraiment question.
Dernière partie : des brassards verts. Nous en avons tous,
il s'agit vraiment de cela.
Je veux dire, il s'agit de choisir des problèmes assez importants pour que cela soit significatif
mais suffisamment petits pour qu'on puisse les résoudre.
Voici encore un des thèmes
qui je pense est clairement ressorti de cette conférence
c'est : Où commencer ? Comment commencer ? Que faire pour commencer ?
Alors, on nous a demandé de concevoir une pompe à eau
pour une société du nom de ApproTEC, au Kenya.
Aujourd'hui elle s'appelle KickStart.
Et, à nouveau, en tant que designers,
nous avons voulu faire quelque chose d'incroyablement beau
et nous avons passé beaucoup de temps à réfléchir à la forme.
Et c'était complètement inutile.
Lorque vous vous mettez à la place de ces gens,
des choses comme le fait que cela doit pouvoir se plier
et tenir sur une bicyclette, se révèle beaucoup plus pertinent
que sa forme. Le procédé de fabrication,
on doit pouvoir la fabriquer avec des méthodes de production locales
et des matériaux autochtones.
Il fallait donc complètement l'imaginer du point de vue de l'utilisateur.
Nous devions complètement nous imaginer dans leur monde.
Alors, ce qui ressemble à un produit pas très gracieux,
est, en fait, extrêmement utile.
Elle fonctionne un peu comme un stepper, vous actionnez les pédales vers le haut et vers le bas.
Les enfants peuvent l'utiliser. Les adultes peuvent l'utiliser. Tout le monde peut l'utiliser.
Ces gens sont devenus - encore, un des thèmes -
ils sont devenus des entrepreneurs.
Ces gens savent très bien l'utiliser.
Et pour nous, c'était super
car elle a remporté des tas de récompenses.
Alors nous sommes en fait parvenus à allier les besoins de l'entreprise,
les besoins des individus dans l'entreprise,
à se sentir à l'aise avec un produit que nous concevions réellement,
et les besoins des individus pour qui nous le concevions.
La voilà, pompant de l'eau à environ 9 mètres.
Alors, comme symbole final nous avons distribué ces bracelets
à chacun de vous ce matin.
Nous avons fait un don au nom de chacun ici
à KickStart, sans vouloir faire de jeu de mot, pour le démarrage de leur prochain projet.
Car, encore une fois, je pense que c'est en quelque sorte joindre le geste à la parole, ici-même.
Pour nous c'est un geste important.
Alors, nous avons distribué des bracelets. Les petites idées font de grandes choses.
J'espère que vous les porterez tous.
Voilà.Merci.
(Applaudissements)